He'd have to stay. Well that's what
I, when I was training for that,
a MMA fight against the comedian.
I trained with Bisping, uh, twice.
And I grappled with this being in
business, not even known for his Jujitsu.
Of course he is. He, no, he's
got very good a brown belt.
I know he's a guard. He's defensive
guards, one of the best in MMA.
Very rarely do people pass his
guard when he's on the ground. He's,
he's excellent. But primarily he, you
know, he's known as a striker primarily,
primarily. Duh. I can't
explain to you. It was like,
I felt like a lion was just
toying with me. It was,
it was, it was a strange thing because
I'd never in my life, cause you obviously,
you know,
an MMA fighter can beat you up.
You don't like professional mixed
martial arts can beat you up.
But I don't think people realize how
badly and how big of the gap it is.
It cause it's not, it's, but
they don't know Joe, you know,
people have no fucking
clue until you do it.
And I had no idea until
this last summer and I just,
and he was fucking around with me for
a second. Yeah. It was terrifying.
And I feel like less of a man.
I can't look at my son in the eyes the
same way that I used to be able to,
I don't fuck right. Like, oh,
come on, you'll be all right.
You know what it's like.
It's like,
um,
do you know how people see someone do
stand up and they think I can fucking do
that? Everyone. That's how we got
started. Because you're just talking.
You guys just talking. Yeah.
That's what fighting is like.
It's like you look at a guy
like Bisping and you know,
he's like a normal guy and he's
obviously very athletic and he's big and
everything like that, but he's,
he's not Shaquille O'Neal.
He's not like get some seven
foot substance specimen.
He's regular size human.
So you're like, well, he's moving
like a regular human. I could do that.
But you have no idea. It is
noisy. You're beyond helpless.
You have no idea. Literally no idea.
He grabbed a hold of you. You are,
you're a dead person. Almost
anybody in the UFC, any, any person.
The average person is, even if
you're training, it doesn't matter.
They can take you,
they'll do what they want to do with you.
There's intellectual levels,
like I always feel like that whenever
I talk to people that are really smart,
like I'm gonna have a Sean Carroll or
Neil degrasse Tyson or someone on the
podcast, he talked to him. He just like,
God damn, I'm fucking stupid. You know,
there's just,
there's levels to this,
this level to this understanding
of life that's like,
but that's with everything with standup,
an artwork with,
with someone choking the life
out of you this day, man.
I been doing Jujitsu since 1996 I'll
roll with certain people. I just,
it's a matter of when I'm
going to get strangled.
They don't even have to be bigger than me.
It'd be smaller than me.
It's when am I gonna tap?
When's it coming?
I had a friend of mine who's like a
really athletic dude who I get each,
he signed with friends, a friend of
a friend, but he trains out of a,
he's like a trainer out of a,
a Gracie school in Florida.
And he told me one time he, he got to
roll with hoists Gracie. And I said, no.
I was like, what was it like? Was it like,
was he like that much better than cause
guys a high level black belt? Like,
he was like, dude, he was like, we're
talking about levels. He was like,
he was toying with me like I had never
done it before. And that's how, uh,
that's how good. Um, those guys are.